but i said if a woman gains like 100
pounds
at that point it's a choice and i would
understand if your partner left
what do you guys think would you stay if
your partner gained a hundred pounds
and you everyone should let the boys
my opinion
is that okay you get married you love
the person as they are ratata but for
example if i was in that boat this is me
speaking a man who whatever if i put on
a hundred pounds and my wife has not
told me in the process like yo you need
to fix up
i would take that as in like yo she's
looking after me my health is not right
but if you put on a hundred pounds
something's gone wrong like
so you're just saying it for like
not the visual for health benefits no
that's for sure but not like
bro 100 yeah
100 pounds that's a lot of weight you're
worried about
a less fiery perspective first but then
visually yeah like
if i if i put 100 pounds of fat like i'm
just like maybe her cooking is fire also
hundred pounds
that's like that effort to put on that
much weight like was it post um
after pregnancy postpartum depression
that's that's what i said though i said
i don't understand 10 20 pounds
and i don't think i don't think men
should just like give you no warning and
up and leave
but at some point it becomes a choice
yeah if you're gaining fifty seventy
thousand a hundred okay go ahead there
are some relationships that they feed
their partner because they like him
bigger so yeah
obviously like if you like a big girl or
whatever like like a bigger guy than
like
that's calm like if you're if that's not
your type
and maybe like you would say your type
is more
what athletic or cyan
and she's strange away from that like
where i kind of like your point in the
fact of um
that if if she or he whatever hasn't
come up to you and said look you're not
looking trim how i first met you what's
going on then and if you're official
what like say for example
if it was just like your boyfriend yeah
and they put 100 pounds would you stay
with him
i'm saying it's not committed though
like it's like true difference if you're
married or if you're if it's your side
i think i just think um
i mean women leave all the time like
women leave the majority of
relationships and only for things for
like not being happy
you know not like they need to define
themselves things like that which is
which is fine i think you can leave for
whatever reason but like sexual
attraction is part of a relationship i
think it's important when people don't
say it's like the first thing that like
oh [ __ ] over personality that's
right you'll see that you need to look
at this person you're ironic about yo
this is like a bad b like on a regular
afternoon of course it doesn't mean that
someone wouldn't cheat or something
won't do this it's like it's a start
because other [ __ ] [ __ ] up
relationships regardless but do not
think like see like river marriage i
think that's like a completely different
ball game so
like you've you've bonded on a different
level so we've gone past like attraction
at this point like we've actually
blended like intellectually
finished let me finish like you you've
gone past like
that attract like there is attraction
don't get existed like that's so
important but there's that intellectual
spiritual like emotional like
that all types of different connections
like to the point like i like personally
that i'm going to encourage you first
but you're a girl i'm going to ask the
guys does it start with the visual or
does it start with the mental health
did it still start with the visual or
the mental yeah
because it's like
no matter what happens in that like
you're going to speak to someone or like
however it starts it's starting for a
reason and it's not
a lot of times it's not starting because
you're like
i think we're going to have really great
conversations like it's time because
it's like
she's attractive
i want to know more even like the most
innocent people i feel like when they
start to see someone they're like look
and be like oh they're attractive let me
go find out more like let me chat to
them like it's never going to be like
oh let me just chat for no reason and
then certain sparks
so so
i'm going to ask the girls
do you think that's wrong do you think
it's wrong for a guy to leave his wife
if she lets herself go and i'm not
talking about
a little bit of baby weight i'm talking
about 100 pounds
50 50 plus that's like 45 kilo for the
british for the british followers here
and and on the same note if your partner
gained that much weight would you stay
or go
i'm gonna try and motivate him so
i'm not gonna leave just because of that
i'm gonna say
hey let's go to the gym together let's
go that's what i'm doing
like oh should yeah go
say that again say it again no i'm
saying like it's just funny the way you
said it's like
i'd be like yo
you've been putting on weight or like
she'd expect her to be like yo you
you've been putting on weight
she went to the gym together
but i think that's a conversation you
have prior to saying oh let's go to the
gym like
i'm assuming that you black okay let's
have a conversation about it so there's
some backstory to that let me let me ask
the men your previous
girlfriends how do you think they would
respond
if you said
that they'd been gaining weight and it
was a problem
that's a mad conversation like a mad
conversation she could actually be cool
because she told me she tells me my [ __ ]
stinks all the time like something about
me like you know what i mean like
i don't take it personally me like i
just think
regardless if you don't know i just
think like for me like just even to say
that would be on my conversation like
okay there's another wedding day and she
comes down
like she asks
was like let's go this is less i've been
feeding you then like where you been
getting
fed up
i don't know if that's rude you guys
think that's rude but
as your partner i agree with you
if you're in it for a long run and
you're together
yeah you're going to have to give them
options right and try and help them so i
think it's different from okay not a gym
but like hey should we go for a walk
tonight yeah you might stay with a
little man if you put a hundred pounds
on them yes
marriage
like you'll be like is this kids as well
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you committed
but i was not working towards losing the
weight there was a problem yeah so you
would leave like you've asked him